Next year systems is a toronto-based software company we provide
intelligent customer management solutions to financial services companies around the world we do business in
North America your Asia and Europe and the Middle East over the last few years
The customers are looking for more out-of-the-box less customized
Solutions and to deliver that we are investing in hybrid cloud
solutions where we offer the solution as a managed service to our customers we chose IBM because as a
Very strong hybrid cloud offering focused around data integration. They have a consistent infrastructure
in data centers around the world
So that we can offer a managed service to our customers and still comply with their data residency requirements
Our objective is to be able to deploy a solution
to our customers in about 15 to 20 percent of the time that we could in the past so
dramatically reduce our our cost of implementation and time to market the
infrastructure offerings themselves
Give us the flexibility in power that we need
To be able to tailor the solutions to the requirements of our clients whether it's a shared infrastructure or a dedicated
Private infrastructure, we can do it both with our same product offering on the IBM cloud
enabling
inteligentes
within our system
and focused around
Not removing the adviser or the end user from the picture and replacing them but augmenting
him with better information better
Suggestions of what to do and why to do it enabling him to do his job better and faster
Because next Jay is required to provide a mission critical application that meets the compliance and regulatory
standards of our customer we need a
infrastructure that supports it and IBM does that